okay
it being 203 I'll go ahead and start
this work session on division three
um uh
so so what is uh my intent for today
certainly we're going to do what we said
we would do we're going to have the
economic security briefing uh I'd also
like us to complete our discussion that
we started the other day on hb2
uh representative Stringham is not here
today did he ask you representative
tolersky if you'd be open to doing the
clerk function in his absence
are you are you ready to do that
okay 42. clock is ticking yeah so
um
so one of the things I I would say to
representative Stringham is um he's been
working a special project on behalf of
division three most of you may know but
because he has such strong experience in
Medicare reimbursement rates and because
we felt like to me that we had come to
the conclusion that we would like to
take a look at some of the Medicaid
reimbursement rates to see if there was
a small subset that we ought to Tinker
with to just make sure that we don't
break anything in the coming two years
that would hopefully buy time for the
Department to go do a complete top to
bottom rate setting drill us for the
next budget so but but I'd like to just
make sure that we stop the bleeding so
on Tuesday when we have another work
session I'm going to ask and would you
remind me let's send an email to Jerry
so that that he knows that on Tuesday
I'd like to have him just tell us where
he's at in that process
I'm not expecting him to be complete or
anything but the nature of the exercise
is we're going to run out of time before
it's complete
because it's it's a bottomless pit of
potential but we have to just get
something done making it better than it
is so so
that's what we're going to do a little
bit on Tuesday today we're going to talk
about Economic Security and we're going
to try to talk about hb2
is there anything I'm missing here Mr
Ripple
nope I don't think so oh okay so so what
am I missing representing money
well we're also going to meet Monday at
10 o'clock
uh all right Mr Wyatt let's let's let's
go ahead
good afternoon Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services
afternoon Karen Hebert I'm the director
for the division of economic stability
now be before you you will see a couple
of different documents
we have our standard presentation
in the PowerPoint presentation we've
also handed out a position movement
document here as well this is similar to
what you've seen for the other divisions
and then in the governor's recommended
budget we will be beginning on page 890
and with that I will hand it over to
Karen
I also would just like to introduce I
have a team of PR Chiefs program experts
here with me today I'm very proud of
them they did accompany me
for this particular presentation so I
just wanted to introduce my team is here
so this division has been was created in
2018 the mission of this division is
essentially to enhance the health
economic and social well-being of
individuals families and communities
so going through the presentation itself
can can we just I I need to get oriented
to the book I believe Mr White said in
the governor's budget we're starting on
page eight nine zero that's correct okay
so uh I'm seeing titles like Child
Development operations
uh child development program are am I on
the right page yes sir you are okay very
good
so if you go to slide three in the
presentation it essentially gives you
some orientation to the structure of
this particular division
there are six primary programs or
bureaus if you will which include
the child of development and Head Start
collaboration
it includes the child support services
family assistance which is two parts
there's field operations for family
assistance and then there is what I
refer to as a business and policy side
of the house
another our questions already Yes okay
so
um I heard you say that this division
started in around 2018 was that the year
that's correct okay and I see the
division Mission would you would you
tell us right up front uh was this a
statutory direction or was this at the
discretion of the commissioner to
establish this division this was
discretion of the commissioner
description discretion of the
commissioner yes sir and and to what
extent
are your programs maybe at a subordinate
level uh associated with statutory
obligations and you can if you would
just tell us that as we go through your
slide deck that would be fine I I just
want to make sure I know the
distinctions between where where we've
exercised good judgment on the part of
the commissioner and and where you guys
are required to do the ridiculous stuff
we ask you to do as the legislature okay
all right sure so each of the bureaus
and or programs do have statutory
requirements uh federal and state so
where I was was with the family
assistance Bureau which is in two parts
so and then we also have the Bureau of
Employment supports
we have what's known as the new heights
Administration that new heights is the
integrated and eligibility and
enrollment I.T system
and also the program known as
comprehensive Family Support Services
so those six primary programs exist but
from a budget perspective the lead
programs here that we're going to go
through are really the child development
and Head Start collaboration
that I will move into child support
services and then the Bureau of family
assistance the other programs are
incorporated into the Bureau of family
assistance budget and I will go through
those
do you have specific slides you're going
to hit on New Heights because I'm gonna
I have some questions on that yes
so the division if you're moving to
slide four you'll see some key outcomes
that I've highlighted this division
directly serves individuals and families
some temporarily
and others with long-term Services based
on their circumstances and eligibility
for different assistance programs these
are economic related services that
people absolutely need
some of them just to survive or to have
basic life necessities
through these Services we directly and
indirectly also support the business
community
this positively impacts the state's
economy
there are cost avoidance components in
each of our accounting units of these
programs which prevent the need for
public assistance
our programs contribute to the reduction
of poverty
we stabilize individuals and families so
that they no longer need or will not
need public assistance and we help those
who do need it
and each program does this in a unique
way
we're there when you need it
and we're there when you can't survive
without it
our programs also support and educate
parents building protective factors such
as concrete supports or resiliency
ultimately preventing child welfare
interventions
on Slide Five you will see a number of
key accomplishments of this division I'm
not going to go through each one of them
but I will say that we have been
successful in strengthening families and
individuals
we have strengthened our infrastructure
so that we can provide greater access to
and delivery of services
and we model on a whole person or whole
family
model of Service delivery
a question on the new case management
practices
to um I know this is something that the
representative hole and I have talked
about is to to what extent do you have
support from an I.T system perspective
to help you
identify the cases
of of support that the Department's
trying to provide who's accountable for
that case and how much time is being
spent on each of those cases do you have
any I.T to do that or do you do you even
try to capture that kind of data sure in
both the systems New Heights as well as
the New England Child Support
Enforcement system uh the acronym for
that is Nexus both of those do
identify
cases individually as well as the
assignment of those cases to each worker
there are also dashboards available for
the caseworker to operate on daily
operational work that they will need to
do then as a result of automation that
is built into the system so that they
know what to follow up on what might
need
what maybe information may be missing
um
a variety of
pieces come up on that dashboard to
drive business in that case
um
so I'm going to start with the Bureau of
Child Development and Head Start
collaboration
and really looking at everything through
I'm going to try to walk through from a
budget perspective on these
particular Bureau
this is all about child care assistance
for low-income families to provide
access to high quality and safe and
reliable child care so that parents can
seek gainful employment
this Bureau as it reads here assures
family access to the child care
assistance program it's formally known
as the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program
we strengthen the child care system in
New Hampshire to support business and
economic development
we provide support and professional
development opportunities to the
provider community in child care
we help parents to make informed choices
to support their own child's development
and choices for their providers that
they wish to have their child be taken
care of
so uh can let's talk about Head Start
for just seconds sure is is this is this
the same Head Start From it's a federal
program that's been around since the 60s
or late or early 70s it is and so so
what the department has done by creating
this Bureau has taken its own State
efforts and initiatives and integrated
it so that it's complementary with the
Head Start program or why are these two
things in one Bureau the federal office
of Head Start requires that states
identify a lead agency that it would
collaborate with
on the state level and for New Hampshire
that agency is the Bureau of child
development
so the name apparently is important to
the federal government that we include
in the name of that Bureau that is a
collaboration it's a collaborative
relationship with the Head Start program
so we provide quality Support Services
to Head Start there's a lot of
collaboration that's done a review of
between rules and regulations that those
two programs need to follow
okay
um now there's been a lot of studies in
the Head Start area
most of which are like either neutral on
the success of Head Start or or not very
complementary that that it's not hitting
its objectives on a sustained basis so
like the kids get some support early
like Pre-K or so and that within a year
or two after that
they are exhibiting the exact same
outcomes as kids that didn't go through
the Head Start program that's what I
think I remember
can you correct me on that or or is that
is that a correct remembering of the
research so far I believe there's quite
a bit of research out there and what I'd
like to do is go back and consult with a
program and then I can provide you with
some current research information for
you to have at your reference but just I
I would take a summary because I'm not
going to be able to read a whole thing
but I I would like to get updated
because the I'm dealing with
eight-year-old information on Head Start
and it wasn't all that great is it is it
pretty is it pretty
is are the Head Start or the Head Start
program components though fairly stove
piped to where they're operating within
their own boundary conditions and
requirements I'm still trying to figure
out the extent to which you're
integrating it with State efforts for
child development
and then I'll go to representative
Wallner so yeah and I I think I would
defer to the Beer Chief and Child
Development to answer that question a
little bit easier than okay if that's
all right
good afternoon hello I'm Deborah Nelson
the BR chief for Child Development and
Head Start collaboration talk talk
straight into the mic otherwise it's
hard for people like me to hear you
can you hear me now
okay sound like a phone commercial
um well thank you for that question and
I'm eager to answer it so the studies
you were quoting focused on academics we
know the business of Early Childhood is
play social emotional development
learning how to learn and being prepared
to succeed when you get to a formal
School setting and Head Start does that
beautifully so so the studies you read
were basically academic studies versus
social emotional and and yes so children
in Head Start when they get to third
grade they don't show different outcomes
on math and math scores per se but they
show Advanced social emotional skills
that help them be too successful
lifelong Learners learning how to learn
learning how to get along with their
peers so those newer studies demonstrate
the critical importance of Head Start
and just to clarify
um so our Bureau does not receive nor
monitor the millions of dollars that go
directly from the office of Head Start
in Washington to local grantees rather
the Head Start collaboration office
there's one of us in every single state
and that was put into the Head Start act
by Senator Kennedy many years ago
purpose being that because it was
Federal to local there was not any
necessarily state level coordination of
what Head Start was doing at the grantee
level so those offices were put in place
basically one-person offices to make
sure that they collect you know they
help the grantees collaborate with one
another and with child care and dcyf and
all the other programs and services
within a state that care about and work
with children and families so that we're
all working together toward the same
things the the beauty of having the Head
Start collaboration office in together
with the with the child former Child
Development Bureau is the capacity to
leverage resources and to truly have a a
functional integrated level of work for
example when we do our credential
revision we look at Head Start
credentialing as well as child care
credentialing when we do our policy when
we built our Granite steps for Quality
quality recognition Improvement system
Head Start voice was at the table so we
were building one system for all so it's
really been you know a wonderful
opportunity to leverage resources and
make sure that all Early Childhood
voices are are heard and that where you
know the services that we provide work
for all of our early childhood folks
okay all of that's beautiful love it
Mr White would you stick our fingers
exactly where the Head Start Start
Federal money is and show us to the
extent if any that there's general fund
requirements there's
um if I'm if it's 125 000 each year
that's no I have to see it no
no so so what what we're referring to
there with the the 125 it's on page 892.
uh to count 29.79 Head Start
collaborative that that's a standalone
grant for Head Start
um I think what's also important just to
point out here is beginning on page 890
accounts
2976-2979-2978 there's approximately
27.5 million dollars of child care
development funds that the state
receives
um to to support these programs and um
part of that's Moe uh we we have to put
forward 4.5 million dollars of General
funds yeah say that number again 4.5
million dollars or the the big number of
the little number
okay and and we're we're where's the 4.5
million is that spread over several
lines yeah yeah so so the the three
accounts the 29 76 2977 and 2978 that
could collectively that's where we have
the the
27.25 million dollars of ccdf so the
child care Development Fund dollars and
there's there's a 4.5 million Moe mixed
with that there's a 50 50 match and then
there's discretionary dollars and those
discretionary dollars are provided by
the federal government and those
fluctuate from year to year so some of
the variation that you see in the
federal funds within those accounting
units that's based on the discretionary
dollars that that we'll be getting over
the next biennium
thank you representative Waller
thank you
um Miss Nelson actually addressed what I
wanted to say and that was that Head
Start receives for the programs in the
communities that's directly that that
program money goes directly from the
federal government to the programs it
does not flow through the department and
this is just a grant to coordinate
between the state and Head Start and
child care and I think what Mr
uh White was just now speaking about was
actually the child care portion of the
budget which is is very different than
from the Head Start portion
correct yes
yes thank you for coming up
okay
so as Mr White was describing uh the
different Federal funding streams that
do support child development so the
first accounting unit here
2976 that starts on page 890.
there is no information in the briefing
book because that particular budget is
under a million dollars so it is not in
the briefing book yet it is the
essentially the back office if you will
it is the Operational Support and
administration of this particular Bureau
it's a hundred percent federally funded
and does provide the Operational Support
for the child care scholarship program
accounting unit 29.77
is the child development program this is
the funding for employment related child
care
this funding also is to meet has meets
State matching and maintenance of effort
requirements
there are just by way of information 624
providers who serve children that
receive the child care scholarship
foreign
give me an idea of what that amount is
that a family might receive to assist
them in this child care
just in very general terms I don't know
I think I have that
or alternatively the number of families
that receive assistance
that are helped by the program
so the number of
families in the program I think it's
approximately three thousand who receive
the scholarship program
and I will have to
find data that I might have about the
average amount that a family receives it
is I believe it varies quite a bit
because it's based on a number of
factors to determine eligibility that
include income household size
um so I'll have to do a little digging
for you that's okay you don't need to go
through all that
my follow-up question might actually
help answer my question
um
is I'm assuming it's a is it a partial
or is it a hundred percent
um scholarship for care it there is a
cost share for parents and that also is
dependent on a number of factors that
answers my question thank you excellent
you're welcome
representative Cole did you have a
question I did thank you I'm looking at
page at one of the
you're calling it the budget briefing
book right and it looks like there the
caseload was 31.79 right dropping down
the 29.56
sorry about that so I'm looking at page
one of the budget briefing book correct
caseload is dropping roughly from 3200
to 29.50 correct and yet the cost per
case the line above it's going from 9400
the first jump this year
or I guess 2023 was in 10 000 rounding
up a little bit to 11 7.
um that's a 17 jump in 24 and then level
funded for 25.
um what was the jump for 24 and not why
was that not split evenly between the
two years I
oh my factor is just the cost of child
care that has increased
fairly
okay over the last few years
so the next accounting unit uh is the
child care development quality assurance
it's 29.78 this is also a book number is
891 briefing book page numbers three
this is also 100 federally funded
and I think it's important to note 12
percent of these particular funds must
be spent on quality as well as infant
and toddler programs
and on the last accounting unit which we
have touched on is 29.79 that is the
Head Start State collaborative that is
100 federally funded
I can move to the next program if you
are ready I I appreciate your pause
there because it's just given me a
chance to figure out where I am in in
the budget book so I think to
representative walner's point that uh
the reason there's very little Head
Start money showing here we're talking
125 000 or so it's because the money is
bypassing the state budget altogether
and going directly to local providers
that is correct okay and then so this
hundred and twenty five thousand or so
even that's Federal money that they
Grant to us to help us administer this
program is that the point okay got it
thank you you're welcome
representable
thank you back to page one of the budget
briefing book
so of this caseload I assume that's the
number of children or is that the number
of families do you know
children thank you so so
um if you had a family with three or
four children that were right being
served is there a way to find out how
many families that is
I believe so yes yes I'm quite confident
about that right so if you had I don't
know hypothetically three children that
were receiving benefits going to
um a daycare or child care center right
you're now paying that person well north
of minimum weight right you could have
them at home with their parent
um potentially well north of of some of
the wages in that right it would be
thirty thousand dollars or north of it
thirty five thousand dollars
in paid expenses for child care for a
family right where there might be a way
to have them say with their parents and
be better off
at a lower rate unless they're making
significantly more than thirty five
thousand dollars
are you
to provide our perspective or the family
the family perspective yeah right so
sure I think that's something that
families are grappling with all the time
and we try to put out information so
that they can make those choices as to
what is going to be helpful for them and
if they qualify for assistance for their
children
um to be in child care services
that would enable them to work they need
to balance that out and make those
decisions but isn't there an income
thresh threshold or eligibility
requirement for these services
yes
so
so uh eligibility levels income
eligibility levels for child care there
are actually six steps for initial
determination of child care so if for
example the first step if you earn 100
percent of federal poverty level which
is uh Eleven Hundred thirty three
dollars a month
um
then there are a number of other factors
that get determined with respect to the
number of children that you have are
they in child care part-time full-time
there's certain definitions for that
that would then determine the amount
that you would get
ineligibility
is that information available
yes okay
yes
so there are different levels of service
for example a full-time level of service
is defined as 31 or more hours a week
There's halftime levels of service and
then there's part-time levels of service
um so there's quite a bit of detail into
the formula it's a little bit
complicated to but I can certainly
provide you with that information and a
link to it great so I have a side
question for Mr White or as we go
through this is this the section of the
budget where the TANF funds can be found
or or is it somewhere else also the TANF
funds will be in a little bit we'll
we'll get there no but it's we're
talking about that today under economic
stability we're going to get the Tana
funds here yep yep I'll point out the
TANF Moe that we have and the Tana funds
that are being used but but in these
accounts these are the ccdf dollars
right primarily and then the Head Start
the 125 000. I'm just I know I have an
open question in my head about the hb2
TANF money so I want to make sure I'm
tracking as we go through the HP one
TANF money to see where that is I'll
draw attention to that when we get there
all right thank you
so if you're good I can move on to child
support services
these are services that are provided to
families of children whose parents or a
parent and caretaker do not reside in
the same household
this Bureau Works to engage and assist
parents who are willing
and able
to support their children or unable to
support their children due to any kind
of a barrier that might be preventing
them from paying such as being employed
and when necessary the bureau will
enforce the responsibility by way of a
legal support order with parents who may
be unwilling to support their children
all right so this is where I'm expecting
to see the term dcyf and it's probably
my own ignorance can you can you can you
help me understand the relationship
between the Bureau of Trials child
support services that sounds very dcyf
like and and dcyf
there is an extremely low number of
cases and referrals we get from dcyf for
child support services okay so you you
receive dcyf referrals and that's what
this is it uh yes we can provide
services to dcyf so if a child is in
placement uh dcyf may want to pursue
child support against one or both of the
child's parents
to um
either help initiate support for
reunification or to reimburse the
federal 4E program title 4E under the
Social Security Act uh paying for foster
care expenditures
um
but like I said we get very very few
referrals from dcyf for those situations
no I just actually had a constituent
reach out to me this week regarding this
very situation and I went digging to
provide the resource and it turns out it
was your office and it was a um
a grandfather reached out to me because
his daughter has four children and the
um the children's father lives out of
state and was refusing to support and so
I did a little Googling and now it's
just all coming together in my brain and
I believe I did the right thing by
directing them to you so thank you
thank you for referring to them yes so
we do provide services when one parent
is here in New Hampshire and the other
parent may be in another state or
another country we do pursue child
support for parents
um despite where the other parent may
live
um
and despite if it's a grandparent that
has
the child has been placed with a
grandparent or other relative or even
what we refer to as fictive Ken so we're
able to provide those services
for folks who apply for it and it is not
based on their income status as well
I'll stop there
so we process approximately 76 million
dollars a year in child support for
families
payments are distributed and dispersed
to families within 48 Hours typically
less than that that's business hours
less than that from the time we receive
them
this absolutely lessens the need for
governmental assistance
and services are really a whole family
approach to Services as opposed to
really being that Law and Order approach
these are Services where we look at the
circumstances of both families including
the paying parent to ensure that they
have uh support and what they need in
order to be able to support their
children so whatever barrier they may be
experiencing we're there to provide
services to them too and connect them
with appropriate resources or other
services that may help them overcome
those barriers
to so I'm just looking at the at the
coloring book here where it says 66
percent are federally funded and then Mr
White I'm looking at page 900 where
under Child Support Services it looks
like the federal match that that
is
no that's about 66 good job
program are funded 66 percent by the
federal government
this is a very cost effective program
for every dollar it spends it collects
three dollars and fifteen cents for
families
this is a cost avoidance program it
reduces the need for public assistance I
have to challenge you I'm sorry you're
probably right still got to challenge
you you say it's cost effective it's
costing us a dollar to go get three
dollars and fifteen cents
if if we were to go out and look at
collection agencies overall as an
industry do do we know how this
benchmarks relative to other efforts to
collect bad debts we've had collection
agencies come to us for help so they do
not have access to the resources that
this particular program does as far as
locating parents and then being able to
not just collect the funds that they may
owe but enforce them so there are a
number of tools that the program is able
to use the collection agencies do not
have and there are regulations about
what a collection agency is actually
able to do versus what the Bureau of
child support child support programs
across the country are able to do in
providing
those services but also the collection
of those payments that have to go
completely to the family so with your
additional Powers you're able to collect
at a higher rate than the typical uh
election agency arguably okay so
um
what are you doing or what could be done
to continually work on improving
efficiency so that it's a dollar for
every four dollars collected what what's
what's the next big thing to get an
improvement in that ratio
so some of the initiatives that the
bureau
barely revolve around the automated
Automation in the I.T system as well as
better services for Access and Service
delivery for parents who want to
self-serve
including things like a online
application instead of paper so having
the convenience of being able to apply
for services online
um being able to look at your case
status and information
through by means of we have a web-based
portal for child support there are a
number of enhancements that we want to
make in that then make it easier to use
including mobile friendly everybody is
making their payments online we should
be able to do that as well we should be
able to have enable parents who are
paying to look up their information on
their mobile phone and that if they
wanted to make a payment that way they
should be able to do it right there on
the spot that would make things a lot
more efficient and getting money faster
to families as well so for what it's
worth so that's great thank you
All-State child support programs are
required to have a state disbursement
unit and this is the union that
processes all the money that comes in
distributed distributes it
electronically to match into our cases
and then disperses the funds by way of
one of three different methods through
through the unit and the primary default
method is by way of a debit card I had
an example I was going to bring it looks
like any other credit card
uh that is the default method we also
enables a very small number of
individuals who want to get a paper
check
there is a customer service component to
the State Disbursement Unit so that
either the paying parent or the
receiving parent can receive information
directly from them we also provide
services through this unit for the
employer community so employers that
have questions about any garnishment
order they can certainly contact the
State Disbursement Unit or to answer
their questions they have a self-serving
portal as well so employers can go on
the portal and see exactly the status of
their employees who may be ordered to
pay support
and what the and the ability to get
billing electronically from the State
Disbursement Unit as opposed to paper
billing
that is another service of the State
Disbursement Unit to manage the billing
of that for self-paying payers and
employers
as I said earlier payments are dispersed
within 48 Hours
um
and that is the State Disbursement Unit
the next unit is known as access and
visitation which is 7933 starts on page
901 of the budget book this item is not
in the briefing book because it is under
a million dollars this is a hundred
thousand dollar grant that the feds
provide that the federal office provides
each year
the idea is that
um
parents who have I'm going to be rude
okay I I want to fast forward a little
bit okay do a quick skip can can we can
we get you to reset at uh page 12 with
the Bureau of Employment supports and I
think that's
page 904 on the on the budget book I'd
be happy to now if I've just caused you
to skip over something important don't
let me make you do that
it's all important but it's all
important that's true
um
no I think that if there are other
questions about the child support
program or Child Support Services I'd be
more than happy to answer them but I can
definitely move
ahead
I was just about done with that anyway
um so the employment supports
this particular Bureau I think is
incredibly important in this division
well they all are really but
this program this is also known as the
New Hampshire employment program or nhep
which this Bureau administers and
provides employment provides Employment
Services to individuals
primarily those who are recipients of
TANF which is temporary assistance for
needy families so for families single
parent families who are receiving
assistance from the TANF program
they have a requirement to participate
in the work program which is the New
Hampshire Employment Program
the idea is to assist them
in many different ways so that they can
become gainfully employed whether it's a
matter of earning skills or just earning
the ability to
find employment whatever they need to do
to be able to do that
we have and maintain relationships with
the employer Community a number of
employers and we have a number of
educational and training programs as
well and have relationships with those
organizations such as the community
college system
to address also labor market needs
through training and education the
bureau focuses a lot on high demand
employment that's needed in the state
and trying to if an individual comes
along and they're interested in any of
those high demand jobs
then we will absolutely
you know promoting those particular jobs
for people who are interested in
pursuing them so so I have some
questions here
it looks like in your in your in the
coloring book on page 13 those this is
32 ftes
as I go to the budget book for the 24
looks like it's 45 ftes so there's a
Delta of 13 I'd like to understand
and then
um and then I have some other questions
sure so in the um the Des position
movement document that I that we handed
out
um that that shows that transfer and so
the the the 32 number that you're seeing
that that's the that was was part of the
original agency budget and from from the
current operating budget and then what
you're seeing there in the 45 that's
included in the governor Governor's
recommended so that's the difference
there
where we were transferring those
positions
um
we were transferring those positions
from account 61 20 uh wait yes uh we
were transferring those into
and they were coming from 7993
or these 13 positions going to do
something different or they have the
same job titles and they're just moving
no they've been repurposed it's a
repurpose correct
so what were they doing that they don't
need to do anymore
so those positions are
family support
service specialist position
in the Bureau of family assistance
and they have been repurposed into this
particular Bureau for employment
counselor career counselor specialist
positions
okay that's close to the answer I'm
looking for
what are they not going to do anymore
process eligibility for applications
from individuals who
apply for any of the eligibility
programs that's what they're not going
to do anymore and they're no longer
needed there because New Heights is more
efficient or some eligibility thing has
happened to where we can do it more
efficiently what what's what's freeing
up I I'm I'm as I really am curious what
did you all do to become so productive
you could move 13 people out of an old
job into a higher priority as
essentially that that particular Bureau
family assistance the family service
specialists
in particular there is a high vacancy
rate there are a number of positions
that despite best efforts to recruit
have not been filled
so let's make use of them where it is
also very much needed to provide
services employing getting people back
into employment so the implication is
this job reclassification makes this a
more interesting position and therefore
you expect to find recruits for this
position these this location as opposed
to the previous location is this a job
enrichment effort basically
you could put it that way yes okay and
then so uh so it sounds to me like good
Manpower management so
um now I'm questioning the head count
though
employment support
45 ftes going against this this is it
just sounds like a really heavy number
when we're running into what feels like
systemic challenges in our Workforce and
I don't know what these 45 are going to
do to really move the needle on that I I
as I understand our Workforce problem is
is that we just don't have the right
qualified people and or the right
motivations to go work and so I'm
curious how this employment support
organization is able to address that is
it changing job skills of the of the
clients or is it changing their
motivation to go work what what what are
you trying to do with these 45 so
they're there are different
prism our employment counselor
Specialists who work with each
individual to develop a customized
employment plan a career plan with them
what is it they want to do and how do we
get them there there's a quite an
extensive needs assessment that's
conducted it's a very detailed
process if you will and then connecting
them with the ability to attain the
skills that they need whether it's
training whether it's credentials and
education and then connecting them with
employers so there are a number of
people other positions in this Bureau
that work directly with the employer
Community to work on apprenticeship
programs on the job training programs a
number of different ways we try to
approach this to support the individual
to become self-sufficient
so there are also administrative
functions in this Bureau with respect to
things like audits quality assurance
compliance monitoring that has to be
done to meet federal and state
requirements
um this is we've changed the business
model for this particular Bureau so for
a number of years the services that we
provide with respect to employment
counseling have been split between the
state employees
and then also through contracted
Services basically doing the same job
there's some issues with that that we're
trying to resolve so that there are
certain functions that only are
contracted with a vendor that they would
perform some of the more
intensity intensifying
um
work with individuals that require a
great deal of time
with them
that state staff cannot do it so they're
focused on a lot of the needs assessment
and individualized planning for people
and case management
the vendor is providing additional in
the interest of time yes okay so
so two big questions
and I'll just ask them both
um
one what sort of success metrics do you
have so that you know that the Manpower
being invested in this is producing an
output that's adequate for the resources
invested that's a metrics question
second question is
um
is is there a rationale why this mission
is more appropriate under the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services relative to the
commissioner of Labor
yes
we provide
quite a different service than
Employment Security or even the services
under the work opportunity
and Innovation act so we work with those
programs but this is a pretty
specialized population that needs a fair
amount of support
and unique attention so that we are
finding success we do case management
and individualized plans where the other
agencies do not really
provide that level of service
sure not not to be argumentative but but
that sounds like a process issue not a
not a jurors issue
is there a specific Nexus between these
clients and the delivery of Health Care
versus
just finding client not just because
it's important but finding these clients
jobs
what what is the what is the Health Care
Connection that that makes us a DHHS
function versus a labor
so the healthcare Connection in this is
so this is about economic stability
which ties very closely with individuals
health
so if you look at so for example the
individual
um maybe a young mother who has a young
child at home
no income no means of getting that
income maybe not even Transportation
no direction of where to go no skill
appropriate to get a particular position
or she would serve or earn a particular
income in order to support her own
family
so we have individuals who would love to
be able to pursue a career but instead
of having the ability to do that they
come to us for services including TANF
or snap
those kinds of assistance that they need
to get by
this takes them a step further and gets
them on a path towards self-sufficiency
so that they don't need those assistance
programs anymore the more people are
able to be self-sufficient the healthier
that they're going to be to be able to
get to the doctor's office to afford
healthy food to afford
care and just
the right child care even
all of that points towards the health of
the individual in the family so is this
function discretionary that the
commissioner established this or was
this statutory so this may be a good
time just to talk about TANF because the
the federal dollars that you do see here
in in this account on page 905
um the the almost 8.9 million dollars of
federal funds those are 100 percent TANF
and then you also see the general fund
match that we have there as well and so
we had talked about this a couple of
times over the past number of weeks
collectively the department has to meet
that 32 million dollar TANF spend in
order to get the 38 million dollars
um and and this is this is one of those
key accounts uh where we use that money
I I think another important thing you
know we're talking and there are also a
number of initiatives that that I know
Karen's team partners with employment
security on so I don't know if it's
worth talking about those relationships
sure
um so yeah there are a number you know
what I think I just heard you say and I
I don't want to I don't want to get you
wrong is is that
we have a challenge in a way that we
have to hit a 32 million dollar level of
effort contribution
and if we don't meet that then we lose
we end up getting penalized in future
years substantially for not having met
that level so it's incumbent upon us to
hit it
and one way that we're contributing
towards hitting it is by taking a
program that doesn't sound to me like it
has a direct Health Care Nexus it sounds
to me like it's all very much Social
determinants of Health which is you know
something slightly different than health
care
uh and but it's close enough that we can
rationalize putting it here and having
it
contribute to that 32 million dollar
level of effort
that that it that it's being wedged in
here a little bit it feels like
I don't know if I'd characterize it as
as rationalizing or wedging in there I I
think it's it's a more more strategic
approach
um that that that has fed into the
current structure today I mean I I think
I and Karen can speak to that sure and
and this actually this particular
program meets Federal requirements that
we have to have a participation in a
work program which is connected to that
TANF program and the funding that we
receive from the federal government that
supports the TANF program so we have to
uh we're expected to have at least a 50
participation rate with individuals who
are receiving TANF in order to get that
Federal funding
and then the other part of the question
was do you have metrics so that we know
that the the level of effort we are
putting into it is having a positive
outcome
yes we are tracking the individuals and
as well as their income uh earned income
that they receive from the beginning so
we have a Baseline and to what they
receive throughout the program and then
when they exit the program or cease to
receive TANF
about how many people are in this client
pool about two thousand about two
thousand so that's a pretty nice cross
section of currently underemployed or
unemployed people have you come across
any epiphanies on what it's really going
to take do we have any magic beans out
there to plant to to more aggressively
move people uh deeper into their
Workforce
model we're hoping to be able to make
this process a lot more efficient and
find those magic beans if you will
um so yeah there are a number of
strategies that we're looking at in
order to provide these particular
services that would
um basically not just earn success but
would be able to report out on it
when might you have a report to tell us
what you're discovering like you know
maybe Child Care contributes to 24 of
the problem substance abuse contributes
to 30
six percent of the problem it's
something that turns into sort of
actionable management of or
underemployed and that's one of the
areas that we want to be able to pursue
is individuals who may be needing to
overcome a substance use dis issue that
uh that they need that kind of support
in order to be employed or if there's an
individual who wants to become
self-employed that's quite an extensive
process in order to be able to stand up
a new business and be self-employed so
this new business model we're really
looking to pursue support from a vendor
to provide that kind of intensified
service and support for our particular
population
who want to go down those paths so I
would say that we would need a few
months to be able to report out on
success of that because we're just we
haven't started this new business model
yet
looking across looking across all these
programs right if there's roughly 2 000
individuals in this last one
how much commonality is it that people
are receiving help looking for a job
receiving help to find child care right
that it's the same pool of people and
are we having the impact back to the
Chairman's question about metrics are
are we actually seeing that these people
are moving from right assistance to
being self-sufficient
and that's an excellent question so I
think that you'll see on my last slide
what I named our challenges that we have
going forward and you know one of those
challenges is really determining how do
we know that people have been successful
because of the assistance programs that
they have been enrolled in and the
services that we've provided them with
there is not a really good answer for
that so we need to be able to try to
what what can we do to make that
determination and there's no answer for
that yet
um so what we've been experiencing of
uh the programs who are we've been
seeing a decline in enrollment uh in
TANF in a number of the state
supplemental programs in child support
in all of these programs we don't know
why
could it be that they're successful
that we're actually successfully
getting people off of Public Assistance
uh but we don't really know that
your comment reminds me of a cartoon I
saw yesterday
and I'll I'll do my best to describe it
but it's worth sharing right day one at
med school and there's a professor in a
gown who's pointing and says every
healed patient is a lost customer
and at some point right if we want to be
successful the goal is to actually
decrease the number of families
supporting so that's that's a win if I'm
hearing you correctly and I guess what
else could we do to help these families
be on their own yeah starting having
been there starting a company is a lot
of work done it twice
um and it's a it's a good example but
what else can we do is is the right
metric is the right knob to turn whether
it's child care whether it's
supplemental
Insurance while you're starting a
company for instance use that example
because buying health insurance is hard
so if you have a family and you're
starting a company on your own those are
real world issues that I want to know
what what areas where there's a lot of
return for investment of time and energy
and effort
and that is also a great question great
questions great direction that we would
want to go in order to go there we need
research we don't have the ability to do
that kind of research and a lot of the
research may actually be out there but
we don't have the ability to analyze it
so what are the answers and how do we
get them how do we know that these
services are being effective are they
just simply underutilized are we not
providing the right access or Service
delivery for people in order to find out
the answers to these questions we would
need more resources to be able to do
that if there are other programs that
would provide that success we would need
the resources to support those other
programs
I'm gonna I'm gonna jump ahead and again
if are there any questions in here
um I I just want to um as as I look
through the division of the Bureau of
family assistance on pages 14 and 15 I'm
seeing a lot of TANF is this is this
predominantly where the rest of the TANF
is and then we we have about a hundred
percent of what's in hb1 and TANF in
these all these sections Mr Ripple
yeah in past years the department has
provided a complete breakdown of all
TANF funds throughout the budget uh
General and federal alike and I think
that's been very helpful to the
committee in the past and I'm wondering
if it's something you could provide this
year as well
sure we can put that together
thanks
okay so so one of the thoughts I had on
this is I I don't I don't remember the
specifics but I think in hb2 we we have
some supplemental money to go to TANF to
make sure that we meet our level of
effort and and sort of this sort of
confuses me because it it feels like the
extent that we want to engage
our systems we would just go ahead and
put whatever TANF money is needed for
the match or the level of effort into
hb1 to drive specific programs so that
the programs
are clearly
resourced in a way in which we can track
them over time you know budget to budget
to budget if we can if we can get the
operations you know routinely working
and Reporting on the same resourcing
that would be good and and I I'm not I'm
not really wanting to put tan of
supplemental money
into hb2 so so my what I'm going to ask
you to think about I'm not going to put
you on the spot is is is there a way to
to take the TANF money you need for 32
million level of effort and invest it in
these programs so that these program
managers start the fiscal the the budget
knowing what they're resourcing are and
what what they can accomplish rather
than you know I know I'm going to say
play a game it's not playing a game I
don't mean it to to be dismissive but I
think division putting in hb2 just
dilutes the communication and value of
having a budget
so um account 6146 906
um that that's likely the location that
we would put those the three million
dollars of Tana funds that's in that's
included in HP what's that
page 906 account 6146 and and so just
kind of stepping back a little bit so
when the department prepares its agency
budget request it has to hit certain
Targets this year it was three percent
from 23 to 24 and zero percent plus
Personnel cost to 25. uh in doing so
um we we submitted a couple of
prioritized needs for those three
million dollars of Tana funds that you
saw within hb2 it would certainly be our
preference to include that within HP one
in the operating budget
okay I was still busy chasing the number
with my eyes and so I missed at least
three critical sentences in there that
you said so so you would prefer to get
the money out of the tan of money out of
hb2 to put into hb1 that's your
preference at the time you were you had
the opportunity to do that you didn't
know where to target it but now you have
a better idea no no so no we we knew
where we wanted to put it but in order
to hit the three percent Target we we
did not we included that as a
prioritized need so during the agency
phase of the budget rsa94 defines our
efficiency expenditure uh Target and
that's defined that's we get further
guidance from the governor's office in
order to hit that we developed those
those figures but in order to hit that
we were unable to include the additional
three million dollars of General funds
within this division so they went as a
prioritized need those during the
governor's process that didn't make it
into hb1 and it was added as an hb2
provision my preference would it would
be to have that as part of our operating
budget
okay so do you have something you'd like
to say
no it sounds like you could just bring
it back from House Bill 2 over to House
Bill one and they will show you where
they need it to go I I I I I would like
to take what you just said and take it a
step further and go ahead Mr Ripley you
have a comment here yeah I was just
noticing that General funds in that
accounting unit do go up slightly from
22 are they are General funds being used
to meet the main the TANF Moe going down
elsewhere in the budget so TANF funds
are across a number of accounts and and
I I agree Kevin I I think it'd be best
for me to provide that that sort of
account overview but yes we increased uh
TANF funds here in order to try to hit
that Moe that the 32 the collective 32
million dollar mle
okay so so you guys are are down in the
detail better than I am but I would just
like to leave you with a an overall task
to work on an hb1 amendment so we can
transfer this out of hp2 into hp1 and
that we can allocate it where we think
it's going to do the most good do you
have a comment
okay
it representative I just want to clarify
I'm looking at hb2 it's we're talking
about page 82 section 253.
to
okay
now now by
doing what I just asked to move it out
of hb2 into HP to spread it out into hb1
are we also simultaneously reducing that
other list that you've uh you're
preparing for us on your prioritized
needs so you would strike it from one of
the prioritized needs because we're
going to take care of it this way is
that is that how that would work uh no
uh it would more so that list that I had
sent we'd be adding to that list and and
you'd be taking it off of hb1 so it'd be
a net reduction on the Surplus the full
Surplus statement for hp2 and an
increase to the operating budget
I see that okay all right good any other
questions in here let's go ahead
representative
just a quick one so would that mean the
FED whether you decide to reallocate
that six million dollars across the next
two years the federal funds and those
accounts would also jump up by twice as
much
no no
no because so so this is a maintenance
of effort it's not a match
um so we already have the the federal
dollars budgeted
um included here but in order to make
sure that next year we don't come up
three million short because if we come
up 3 million short in in 24 if we don't
spend it all then in 25 States we don't
spend say we spend 29 million something
like that this in 25 instead of getting
38 million from the feds would get 35
million and then we'd have a 3 million
dollar penalty on top of it
okay so I get that part but there's a
two-to-one match with the
Federal funded General funds for the
Tano the mou is not part of that
can't be part of that it's a separate
thing
so so the the maintenance of let me back
up so the maintenance of effort
requirement the state collectively
doesn't matter which account it's in has
to spend the 32 million dollars on what
on TANF eligible purposes okay you know
there are four purposes of TANF it has
to meet one of those four
okay but also the okay so that's great
but then you also have the the matching
part component there's a federal piece
and a general fund piece that's also
being spent on TANF eligible blah blah
blahs right so so the 38 million dollars
that we get from the feds if we hit that
Moe that the TANF dollars we can use
those dollars for those purposes
um we also have a TANF reserved I think
probably a couple weeks ago we talked
about that last I had checked around uh
the beginning of the year we had
approximately 67 million dollars of TANF
federal dollars in our Reserve that
could be utilized for TANF eligible
purposes as well
I guess what I'm trying to understand is
this Moe is it separate from the two to
one matching stuff uh there is no match
it's a maintenance of effort what's the
two to one ratio you mentioned earlier
in the
uh in here you had mentioned 66 what
were we talking about that that was a
separate
yeah yeah that's child support that's
child support
oh okay okay so TANF is a straight we
spend this and we'll you'll get that
yes
yeah yeah okay there was a lot of
discussion there and I saw some some
assertive animation in the audience
do any of you feel a compelling need to
say something at this point
okay all right I don't want anyone
exploding back there Rebecca Lord and is
our is our esteemed Finance director in
this area so all right okay
um
all right so so do you know where we're
at because I've jumped around on you and
then you took a slide Trail I I think I
I think I would just as soon have a skip
forward
um and I can do that so the programs
that are on slides 14 and 15 uh these
are our
State supplemental programs uh many of
them until you get to actually really
slide
um uh 16 which starts with a community
service block grant but 14 and 15 really
are those State supplemental programs
which some of them do meet TANF Moe and
some of the meat Medicaid Moe okay so
one of my special subjects this time
around are Refugee grants and
um
I I I have worked uh with uh OLS to
develop uh an hb2 item that this is to
let the division know and to to let you
know is that um
what what I what I what I what I'd like
to do is to
recognize it for state that for the
federal money going into the refugee
program
believing as I do that the term Refugee
has been abused in order to open our
borders I I would like to do what we can
do to protect New Hampshire residents
and citizens by uh forever for the State
dollars
having
U.S citizens and and New Hampshire
residents have
first right to any service that does
social determinants of Health supports
and if after
fulfilling the needs of our own
residents if there are still resources
available at the state level I'm not
talking about Federal because the
Federal's got their own rules and we
have to comply with those but just for
the state resources
if there's resourcing available after
taking care of our own residents
then I would like to make it you know
then we would just go ahead and make
that available to the federally
defined category of refugee
you don't have to make a comment on it
it's it because this is as much for the
division to let you know that this is
kind of a controversial thing I don't
think it is I'm just trying to make sure
that as we put money into our social
determinants of health programs
that
we prioritize the people who've been
here for years who've been paying in and
building the system and that anyone
who's a new arrival
has to wait in their place in the line
basically
so so that that's going to be an hb2
item that we'll end up discussing as
division three and that you'll see and
and so when you look at it I'd
appreciate it if you would take it back
to the department and just talk about
how you would implement it if it were to
become part of hb2 go ahead represent
plorsky no I'm just going to clarify
that this section we're looking at here
with with Refugee grants is 100 Federal
money so what were you talking about
would not apply here
you may be right there's another section
in here where there was general fund
also Associated under a refugee program
and I may have gotten myself confused
yeah it's completely different thing
there are two are there two different
things or is there only one thing that's
cool it's a different thing we heard
that presentation last week sometime
correct yep that was the division of the
office of Health Equity office of Health
Equity yes oh so everything I said would
be wrong today but if we went back in
time correct
no no it's always it's always good for
somebody to remind me of where I am in
the time space continuum thank you
um
all right so so this kinship Grant and
the snap incentive on page 16. I I think
I think we have active legislation or
issues going on in these areas
so could you could you tell us just talk
about these two programs sure so that
the kinship grant that is an 86 percent
generally funded program this is
connected with dcyf and the New
Hampshire children's trust that provides
this program for those kinship families
providing services for children or
accepting placement of children so that
they receive the same supports and
information
for navigating all of our systems to in
order to
take care of those particular children
that are not their biological children
this
includes there is a prioritized needs
request that we had for this particular
item which is a million dollars per
state fiscal year 24 and 25. this
originated out of Senate Bill 444 in the
last session and this is essentially a
continuation of that support
so what incremental stuff would we be
buying with the extra million dollars
what would we be doing with it that we
aren't doing without it
so a lot of it would go towards support
training for individuals who perhaps
need services that have experienced
something known as Aces the adult
adverse childhood experiences and a lot
of after effects that come with that
where they really need certain support
and Care
through our particular systems
in taking care of somebody else's
children so there's task force involved
with that there's training that's needed
educational sessions further supports
for these particular adults who are
taking care of children that are not
their own
so this is this is training for
clients as opposed to employees so that
these clients can better service it's
training and to support services are
being provided out of Family Resource
Centers I'm sorry I didn't make that
clear
um so the New Hampshire children's trust
supports fine the Family Resource
Centers around the state
so this particular grant program rather
this accounting unit would
further enhance those particular
Services through the New Hampshire
children's trust to support the
infrastructure of those Family Resource
Centers
the snap incentive program that was
originally a program that was created in
New Hampshire the legislature to support
it's 100 General General funds excuse me
this is not in the briefing book it is
under a million dollars
it's actually a hundred thousand dollars
specifically for
educational purposes uh and to support
incentives for folks who are snap
recipients to encourage them to buy
healthy foods so it's known as a double
up food bucks up to twenty dollars a day
you can double the value of your benefit
by buying
fruits and vegetables and other healthy
foods so so this is for um Mr Ripple
maybe
um
or Mr White but okay so the 40 000 the
39 3 that's showing up under 22 was that
I wasn't that really under 23 and not 22
uh and and because we we did a
supplement to give them like thirty
thousand dollars I thought
and and then as the hundred thousand
uh in the next two years
is is that what God agreed to when we
did that new snap uh authorization
or is that higher or lower than what we
had agreed I'd have to go back and take
a look at the bill so Mr White seems to
know something yeah so
um
in in chapter 91 laws of 2021 section
403 there is an appropriation made for
150 000 for this program for the
biennium
so what you're seeing there is you you
see in in the first year that was the
actual spend
um but that's not it's nothing's showing
up there in the adjusted authorized I
believe because it was an hb2 Provisions
so the hundred thousand dollars that you
see here
um it's a slight increase if you took
the 150 and divided by two and added
twenty five thousand
um that's included in the governor's
recommended budget
okay I I
I I think I I think when I got involved
with this last year that we committed to
a dollar level and that was agreed upon
by all the parties and I would just like
to see that agreement kept
I I think I I think it was a a different
number than a hundred thousand each year
it was a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for the biennium which is what
what was in hb2 for the appropriation
okay so this could be this ought to be
75.75 if we were to keep the agreement
okay yeah so it there was 50 000
appropriated for the for half of one
fiscal year and then a hundred thousand
for the next fiscal year so because it
was a delayed start so
it we didn't cover the full first fiscal
year right so so what we did was because
we had missed last year's uh July to end
of our beginning of October window for
the SNAP benefits we put in like thirty
thousand dollars so you had opportunity
to get the system up and get anything
you needed printed printed get everyone
educated and informed so that this year
on July 1 we would put the money in to
actually fund the SNAP benefit that was
all one part of one big agreement uh and
I'm I'm just I I wanna
maybe representative tolersky is going
to correct me I'm talking about
something totally different but but I I
think this was where we made it a
specific agreement to provide 30 000 to
get the program up in the current year
so that we could begin executing it on 1
July with this budget money
and it's not a lot of money it's already
we've already talked about it longer
than it's worth but I just I just want
to make sure that when we make
agreements that we keep agreements
and this is a place that I'd like to
come back and look at offline
representative or if you have something
yes thank you but I don't want to
interrupt you because I want to go
backwards
so
just a while back we were talking about
the Family Resource infrastructure of
hb2 is that number section number 254
yes yeah yes it is so we're essentially
saying that that would go somewhere in
the budget here
in the HP one budget yes yes so the the
legislation from the from this past
legislative session appropriated one
million dollars so this is essentially
keeping that appropriation level at the
same rate
can you tell me what account it would go
into
they don't tell me right now but can you
and there's any reason we shouldn't put
that into the HP one again kind of like
we talked about with the other one
so for that we're looking at accounting
unit 7216.
it's just a kinship Grant yeah and I I
don't see for from my perspective I
don't see any reason not to I would
defer to you on that
it it would be best to have it in the
operating budget so it's clearer for us
to track it from a just you know
transparency accounting perspective but
it it functionally it also works in hb2
I've got the functional part but Clarity
for me is important too and Stefan hb2
is completely unclear to me I could
never made an association between where
it is an hp2 and what it belongs in okay
so maybe Mr Ripple you wouldn't mind
keeping track of that one thanks
any questions
yeah
all right
we have thrown you completely off not
really no can we talk about new heights
I think we're still on track and yes
we're pretty much there the bureau
family assistance uh this particular
um group of accounting unit is really
all related to field activities uh so
the first one is field oh it's known as
field eligibility and operations that's
accounting unit 7993 which is primarily
uh staff who process eligibility
applications and redeterminations
uh and making decisions on individuals
eligibility
the next accounting unit is New Heights
uh number 7214
there are various funding sources that
support this particular
okay go ahead
when you say
7993 is primarily staff it has a huge
benefits number in there too doesn't it
or I'm misreading this
which would go hand in hand oh they do
well Staffing yes
if that's for paying your staff
I'm sorry
so so all the staff members up top I got
it okay yeah yeah it's it's on the prior
page the the class 10 on page
um 913 and then for the Governor's
recommend recommended budget there's 358
positions here so there's there's quite
a few people in this in this account
okay so so yeah go ahead
of the 358 what is the current vacancy
in that area
uh so the vacancy rate for the entire
well I can either tell you for the
entire Bureau uh which the vacancy rate
is 16.3 however I really narrowly look
more at the eligibility staff
specifically when I'm looking at vacancy
rates because that's where a lot of the
impact is happening right now that
vacancy rate is currently 20 percent
okay I I gotta ask you my it geeky
questions okay new heights is a program
and the name of an I.T system both is
that true
yes it's it's both I refer to new
heights they have a whole Administration
right that supports the ideal processes
correct and the I.T system is also
called New Heights correct it's all
interchangeable yes okay and so new
heights uh was an advance that I think
we paid to upgrade in the last budget
cycle
um
has has that upgrade been completed or
are we good on uh the upgrade efforts to
new heights I I think that is a constant
uh with uh enhancements uh that are
needed in this particular I.T system
this is quite a large system that
supports many programs across the
department including Medicaid
Eligibility So when you say supports
many programs my understanding is it was
intended to support all eligibility
efforts within the department yes okay
it does okay yes so even though it's
it's kind of located in your area this
is a department-wide eligibility service
correct it provides a number of other
services for programs in the long term
supports and services Bureau Behavioral
Health there's a number of
um enhancements that are built into the
system to basically replace
other systems and other areas of the
department that are at the end of their
life cycle so so uh this is an I.T
questions and Mr weers isn't here but I
I'd be curious
to know where we are because we did
invest in upgrading new heights I and
and it was in part because we wanted it
to do
eligibility across the department
and that in doing so the way I remember
it is that uh it would take some Legacy
systems and let us shut them down and if
we shut them down that would have a
budgetary impact because we're no longer
supporting an expensive Legacy system
and so as we look at these budgets on
things that we're spending money on it
would periodically be nice to see where
we can do some Reclamation because we
have made good Investments letting us
save money elsewhere I I don't have
visibility of those unless you think Mr
Wieters has already told me and I've
forgotten so there are a number so we're
doing exactly as you just described okay
basically
um like I said replacing a lot of those
systems that are Antiquated
with more efficient processes and be
able to manage them more efficiently in
one contained I.T system
so I can get you any more detail about
that I can tell you that there are a
number of enhancements being made
currently for long-term supports and
services
as well as a number of covid related
enhancements that are needed for federal
reporting
ongoing support for the unwind efforts
so there are further amendments that are
currently in process in order to
accomplish those tasks there's other
reportings related to snap TANF
a number of things that I are system
techie uh things that I can't describe
very well
um so
that's just an ongoing
body of work so like I said there are a
number of enhancements right now there
are 36 pending priority projects with
new heights that are happening now
um but that list is ever
growing changing sure
so I I guess Mr White I'm not act I
don't need the data but it would just
comfort me to know that somehow within
your your processes your budget
processes you're seeing the unwinding of
Legacy systems and the shutdown and the
termination of the maintenance tail
because that's a way to free up
resources that we may put into the
budget thinking we need it for two years
and if you really only need it for six
months then you got 18 months to play
with yep and that's part of our regular
process actually came from a meeting
earlier where we were looking at our
capital projects that were funded and
asking okay so this we haven't spent a
dollar there's thirty thousand dollars
left here why why is this still on that
why is this still on HP 25 so I mean
that that's something that that we go
through on a regular basis and Dave
Wieters again I mean he's he's the he's
driving that ship you know when it comes
to managing each one of those projects
and works with the finance team
to close those out
all right very good any questions
do you have any sort of final thoughts
that I may have stepped on that you you
wanted to say but didn't
uh no I think the final accounting unit
uh is the disability determination unit
which is in this group which is number
um this is 62 federally funded
uh that's the last accounting unit and
then just my last slide that really
provides you with the key challenges
that we have right now Workforce like
everyone is a common uh theme uh that's
impacting Service delivery
um
we are working very hard for operational
Readiness of the Medicaid end of
Medicaid continuous enrollment
um
there the our capacity to manage what's
coming is uh and indeterminate at this
time
but we're doing our best to try to
increase capacity wherever we can
um
another note that's a challenge to me is
that a number of our systems I don't
just mean it systems but business
process systems that are primarily based
on legal compliance which you know
rightfully so however Less on
person-centric Focus
and models which makes Service delivery
I think sometimes a bit challenging so
really trying to shift uh processes
looking at things through a customer
lens I think is really important
um and then of course as we mentioned
earlier the need for research and the
need to understand better about our
enrollment a declining enrollment in our
programs
go ahead
this is probably something we'd say at
the end but I just wanted to tell you
how much I appreciated you putting the
budget page number
and your hand out and maybe Mr White can
advise the other departments to do the
same so we're not always trying to
figure out what page we're supposed to
be on thank you
just thank you
okay
it's terrible
I'm ready okay
all right so I need a moment to
transition
thank you for coming appreciate it
oh one I do have I'm gonna pull a
Columbo on you I do have one more
question
okay so for the division of economic
stability relative to the entire
Department of Health and Human Services
how big a percentage is this division
are we talking about 10 percent of the
general funds we're talking about some
other number
do you know
how big how big is this
if you give me a moment I can pull up a
document it may just take it okay I'm
just trying to get in the ballpark to
figure out how big it is
I I could even figure that out if I just
looked
so so for division three well Mr White
is doing that I think I think we're
looking at this document
is that what we are we're on uh the one
title hb2 is introduced for 24.25 dated
March 6th
well we this is what we were we were we
were using this as a cheat sheet we got
down to 78 section 227.
there are no page numbers
thank you
uh oh on this chart
yeah yeah so that's about page uh
picks
up the hand though she's looking she was
looking at the bill
where did we leave off you got through
Section 226 on page 78 and you'd start
off with 227 sure
yes
okay
foreign
yeah I'm
you know just take me a minute I I have
a table I just want to find it sure
points being difficult
sure
uh section 227 on page 78 extends until
June 30th of 2025 the Department's
ability to transfer between personnel
class lines with prior approval of the
fiscal committee and as representative
pointed out in an email to me earlier
today this one has appeared in previous
trailer bills but I didn't include it in
the list that I sent out yesterday
so this
has been included in four of the last
six trailer bills it was not included in
2013 or 2017 and it has been a little
more controversial than some of the
other boilerplate sections because it
does impact the lapse so most agencies
lapse figures come out of their
personnel class lines so if you allow
departments to transfer between
personnel class lines their laps might
go down a little bit and that's that's
why it was left out in 17. I don't
remember why it was left out in 13.
do you all have any history on that
do do you wanna do you want to do
anything to try to make this more
permanent or are you okay with just
keeping it going as we have
I will say I didn't hear you
how about we delete it you want to
delete it
okay I guess I would like to hear maybe
Mr White tell us about why this is
important to the department to have this
flexibility sure so
if
and I'm sorry I was multitasking so so
we're talking about section 227
excellent
so the department is often responding to
emerging needs and I mean I can give one
more recent example so the senior new
Services Center this past fall we were
having extreme sapping challenges over
there so because we have this ability we
were able to transfer those dollars from
some of the vacancies because after
after this past July when there was uh
you know there was an impending closing
date of March 1st that has since been
eliminated we had a I think we lost
about 33 percent of our staff so because
of that we were because of this
provision we were able to transfer funds
into a contract line and temporarily
bringing bring in staff you know through
through a contracted provider in order
to to bridge that Gap in a temporary way
um I mean I think that's just kind of
one example of the flexibility that that
this gives us
um Now flip that around what would the
process have looked like if you had not
had this flexibility
well
um any of the dollars in those Personnel
lines would have lapsed so it would have
increased the overall general fund lapse
and I
would have probably either needed to fun
find some kind of hp2 provision that
appropriated funds for some other
purpose take money away from that or
amend an existing contract and decrease
the price limitation and eliminate
services
or try to piecemeal something together
through smaller equipment lines or some
other smaller line that that may
otherwise potentially lapse or delay
some type of purchase that was that was
previously approved so so this is what I
think I just heard you say I think what
I just heard you say was that the need
to be able to move money around to fund
other personnel
it would would not go away what this
does is it makes the task of of moving
the money transferring the money much
more easy much more flexible and and and
that gives you more time to focus on
other things and that and then if we if
in that in the given that we can
anticipate serious Workforce issues in
the next two years as well this kind of
flexibility seems to be as important as
it has been in the past two years yeah
it it creates a nimbleness and I mean
any of these transfers I mean we come
through fiscal we present those before
the fiscal committee
um and and it it allows us to be able to
respond effectively without with you
know without a detriment to any existing
Appropriations for specific projects
um or or or services or needs
um so I I would agree with your
statements representable I I it wasn't
my state I was just trying to make sure
I heard you right you know okay
so if this wasn't in the Budget Trailer
bill could you still go to fiscal and
ask for that permission to transfer
between departments or not
uh the the Personnel lines yes no so so
um if you look at if you look at the
language
um
so it's it's delaying excuse me
it's it's essentially
delaying the removal of that Authority
um so if and and Kevin please correct me
if I'm wrong if it's in a class 10 or
Class 12 most agencies aren't able to
move those funds that's correct other
agencies
are unable to move between personnel
class lines
thank you
representative Wallner for a question
I think um representative Edwards
actually made the point that um I think
the flexibility that the department
probably needs to move fairly nimbly
and I mean these are sort of like
emergencies that come up
and you have to transfer staff to from
one place to another so that is correct
so I mean most recently you know we had
Flooding at New Hampshire hospital so we
have several hundred thousand dollars of
repairs to do as a result of pipes
bursting when it was negative 40 degree
wind chill
um I mean I think that's just another
example because we do have the 24 7
facilities
um and then you know I I I think not
that everybody want to relive relive
this but you know during the pandemic I
mean that's just kind of another example
of where we had to respond to some type
of emerging crisis
um and and this Authority allows us to
do that effectively and it's not we're
not able to move these funds without
um you know without fiscal approval so
there's still an oversight process there
to make sure that whatever we're doing
is is approved by the legislature
yeah I'm fine I guess I don't see what
why DHHS is unique with respect to every
other department of the state
I
um
I find that our our day-to-day business
um and I'm I
presents new challenges and new issues
uh almost on a regular basis and and I I
mean I think you can see that reflected
in in the news for For Better or For
Worse
um there are often a number of emerging
issues that we have to respond to and
um this just allows our department to be
able to do that a little bit more
effectively and and I would defer to the
other agencies on on what their business
needs are
um I've I've worked in other agencies
and I I've certainly found that there
has never been a day at the Department
of Health and Human Services in my five
years there where I'd watch the paint
dry on the wall so to speak it is always
busy there is always something happening
some new issue to respond to
um I I can't state that enough
may you live in interesting times
so
um okay so there was a suggestion to
delete it the suggestion to keep it the
same I I feel like the consensus is
basically this is probably pretty good
and of course you're going to caucus on
it no but this is probably okay
all right
okay
okay section 229 establishes two
unclassified positions and abolishes two
classified positions
I guess Java's question is is where and
why are they in hp2 sure so um these
these are two positions that have had
enhancements
um for a number of years and the
division of personnel have actually
they've actually requested that that we
make these that we make these positions
uh unclassified given the nature of
their work it's it's a it's within the
vision of Medicaid services it's a
Medicaid Pharmacy director in the in the
pharmaceutical service specialist
um they're a little unique when looking
at the classified system and and based
on the kind of the the workload hours
worked and the salary schedules
um this this was a recommendation from
the division of personnel because again
we have to go back through and I think
we've been going I don't quote me on
this but I think for close to 10 years
through GNC to get these constant
enhancements to make them competitive
with the market
so do you have an account number
as opposed to the name
and are you saying they cannot be in the
budget because of these specials so so
what this would do is this would
transfer the funds and and I I can look
it up
um this would transfer the funds from
class 10 to class 12 to an unclassified
position
and and it would also convert them into
this in the system to unclassified right
but it doesn't have to be in there every
biennium or can it just be something
that's done this if you if you approved
this language here this would be one and
done then you never see it again okay
thank you
and you need to have apparently some
statutory authorization to make a
conversion to unclassified and this
would be it rather than a separate bill
that's 100 correct yes all right
next
and likewise
section 230 establishes certain
unclassified positions and abolishes
certain certain classified positions and
appropriates funds
in each year of the biennials
so I would think representative hole you
would like these because this is doing
what you thought intuitively we needed
to do is to move more positions from
classified to unclassified
having having reviewed the organization
chart under the commissioner I think all
of these are direct reports up through
the legal department at for these but I
was thinking far more broadly than that
than just
right the entire staff within the legal
department
other than the administrative admin
positions so your position would be this
is necessary but really not sufficient
probably
I think it's a start I don't know and
we'd have to ask questions regarding
how much overtime what's right some of
these C varying workloads there's
there's a an ongoing case right now
against the the state for prior synonym
and YDC
abuse cases I don't know if this is all
being farmed through outside resources
from legal department or if if this is
being managed internally with these 30
attorneys and
how that it would impact the budget
sure
um so I I would have to bring Melissa
sincere into
um she's our chief legal officer I I
would need to bring her in um to speak
to some of those specifics but but again
what what this is doing is we have a
number of classified attorney positions
um their workloads are often their work
hours you know are often driven by the
cases so sometimes they have to be in
court all day and then prepare a brief
for the subsequent day
um and and that's part of the reason and
and the Department of Justice had had
recommended that we take this approach
as well with these particular positions
um because if you work you know if you
work 45 hours every week you earn a
bunch of comp time you never can
actually take that comp time and then we
you know have to make a payment at some
point for that so this was a
recommendation by them and in order to
give them the the flexibility to
um to to manage their their hours in
such a way I've believe many of the
cases that you're referencing
representative whole the Department of
Justice represents the state but then uh
various attorneys across the legal the
legal team
provide assistance with any requests
resulting from from that litigation
so
represent waller or did you have a
follow-up
okay
I just wondered if the attorneys listed
here as having
being reclassified
um
to unclassified
realize that this is happening
I would need to talk to Melissa sincere
about what kind of communication plan is
in place okay thank you
I
if you have more to add I'm generally
okay with that
correct
okay so if no one if somebody's not okay
with that you know let me know but it
seems okay uh
231 establishes that no admissions to
the forensic psychiatric hospital shall
occur until after June 30th 2025 unless
necessary funding is appropriated
okay
that's that's a blinding flash of the
obvious why why does that need to be in
law
it it essentially does what it does
um I mean I I don't think it's necessary
the facility probably at this point
won't be built until mid-2025 so we're
really not looking at the fall
um and or you know the potentially early
winter of the subsequent biennium we
don't have any funding uh for personnel
so
this could go it could stay
it's just sort of under my my general
desire to get hb2 skinnier
I if if it isn't necessary I just didn't
get rid of it it doesn't feel necessary
representative Waller and then tlersky
I mean I I don't know if I look at it I
would think would it
may have been there for us if by chance
some miracle the building was
completed in January of 25.
that because you would have no budget to
run it you would have no operational
budget no one would be committed there
that is correct that's what just
anticipated right that it might have
gotten finished with no when there was
no budget in place yes or early on in
our agency requests we were anticipating
an earlier opening date
um that has not that will not be the
case and so we sent zeroed out uh the
request for the forensic facility staff
all right so so I'd like to just mark
this for deletion
[Music]
unless it doesn't make sense but right
now it seems like it does 232
32 states that the department shall be
able to carry forward funds from fiscal
23 in the developmental Services
acquired brain disorder and In-Home
Support funds and I would just note that
this ability is already authorized by
RSA 171 a8b which makes each of those
three funds non-lapsing and continually
appropriated to the Department
just so the takeaway is this is already
in law and this uh the the this section
might be redundant it seems that way to
me I don't know if Nathan has a
different perspective
so it
the funds that are the the dollars that
are that are continually appropriated to
these funds and and Kevin I don't know
if you know the answer they are General
funds um we're currently projecting
about a 55 million dollar carry forward
um in the in the DD account
um how that would be represented within
this budget is is kind of an open
question whether we would need these
funds for 2024 and whether we would need
this explicit language is kind of an
open question because typically when we
have a continually appropriated
non-lapsing fund like a revolving fund
we have a very we have a specific
funding source and typically that's
non-general funds
so in each case the statute reads the
fund from Appropriations provided in and
then it names the accounting unit shall
be used to carry out the provision of
this chapter the fund shall be
non-lapsing and continually appropriated
to the department so to me it seems
clear that from whatever Source
including General funds
they're known
it seems to be sorry it seems to me that
this language isn't needed
so so with that I I would lean to
wanting us to delete this hb2 item and
give the department an opportunity to
come back to us and say no no no we
really need that
but it sounds like the the statute's
already in place
the statute is in place and I can send
out a link to this to everybody so they
can read it for themselves
um I would note that including it
doesn't hurt anything it might be
redundant at most but it doesn't hurt
anything so so that itself is hurtful
you know I I don't know waste let's be
clean go ahead represent but somebody
must have thought there was a reason for
this to be here and I guess I'd like to
hear
what they were what what was what were
they thinking when somebody wanted
somebody wanted this in here yeah I
think the governor woke up one night and
said oh let's do this
I mean when when we were looking at this
we wanted to make sure that it was
abundantly clear that we would be able
to carry forward those funds and and
again
um typically our non-laps and
continually appropriate funds have a
fixed funding source so like Governor's
commission they have they have a fixed
fund or they have a funding source
depending on the year
um they have a funding source that is
separate from the general funds and we
just want to make it abundantly clear
that those General funds would be
available so that when we send a memo to
das to carry those funds forward in the
next year there were no questions asked
and we had that Authority
thank you sir
the county cap
section 233 on page 80 caps County
Billings for long-term care services at
134.5 million and 24 and 137.2 million
and 25 and those numbers reflect uh two
percent increase of year over year
so my suggestion that I made the other
day was that we just freeze it at the
2023 level
I I think I'm good with that and uh I I
had a conversation earlier with Mr
Ripple and it sounded like
we needed to find about 18 and a half
million dollars to kind of make this
happen it's not in the governor's budget
so as you recall there was a discrepancy
between House Bill 2 and House Bill one
so the figures appropriated in house
bill one were short of what you would
need for the house bill 2 language so I
think there's a technical fix of about
10 and a half million dollars that would
need to be done no matter what and then
there's another eight million dollars to
freeze the county cap at the 23 level
is anyone opposed to finding the 18 and
a half million dollars to to execute
this hb2 line item
I like the idea of freezing it I think
that's a great idea
um but I would want to see where we're
going to find
I want to be sure I know where where
we're finding this 18 million
I think we should put it on a list of
things we want to do
and we'll have to balance it against
things we might not want to do so so Mr
Ripple and I rehearse that for the first
time today and and I I I think there's a
method for us to to do what you just
asked
um I don't have it scheduled yet oh okay
I was going to say are you going to
share or you're just going to give it to
yourself I'm the open and transparent
guy remember
okay
all right so so I think I think we're
aligned on this
so we can go to the next one
okay section 234 on page 80 appropriates
funds the choices for Independence
program
can I ask a question
so can you explain to me
how this
um this is above and beyond
the three percent
correct
and do we have a way of knowing where
this gets
um I want to try to figure out where
this gets them to
sure so what you're seeing here again
similar to some of the other issues that
we've seen it's kind of a function of us
trying to hit that three percent and
then we had leftover prior I don't call
them left over we had prioritized needs
outside of that and then
um these were the amounts that that were
appropriated in hb2 and so the dollars
here um these are based on
um these would ensure that we have
adequate funds to provide services for
existing levels as well as additional
projected service level needs
but does that mean you're talking about
additional services but not necessarily
a rate increase
additional service is not a rate
increase yes here yep
and this is the group that can't hire
anybody to
I mean
I'm having a hard time understanding how
they're going to provide additional
services
when their rate is so low they can they
can hardly hire anybody so that's not
for you to
just just a comment
so this is one place we could find funds
to help with the county cap
e i okay so so I may be wrong but my
reaction to this was just a little bit
different my my reaction is that I think
in general the CFI program is is a good
investment other than what
representative Wallner just pointed out
is that you can throw money at something
without the people to execute it if we
don't change the rates we're not going
to end up spending on extra Services
anyways I I think that was your your
observation
um I I my thought on that would be
putting aside that practical problem I'd
rather see this principally
to put into hb1 instead of hb2 just put
the money into the operational budget
and
and let the people who execute that
program know what they've got
so but if you can't spend it you know
the nursing homes need it they can spend
it
they will spend it
um
so what would this instead of additional
services
what would this Tran Translate to
in if we used it as a rate increase for
these providers
I I don't know off the top of my head so
so so if we took the full roughly 15
million dollars instead of instead of
maintaining the service levels today for
the next biennium
increase that by the equivalent amount
is that that's the request correct yes
sure um yeah we can
I I can come up with a figure
and and get that get that to you okay I
mean
I think that yeah
you could take the money and put it at
the nursing give it to the nursing homes
but nursing homes cost
so much more we're doing this is such a
better
way of providing Services it's it's a
lot less expensive to keep someone in
their own home with help than to have to
go to an expensive nursing home I just
saw a nursing home budget this morning
in Merrimack County I mean we're talking
200 to 250 000 a year per person
so so I think these are two distinct
issues two distinct issues they are we
we and and maybe we should keep them
separate a little longer to say we we
we're I think we're committed to trying
to keep the county cap as it was and
that we have to find the 18 and a half
million dollars
representative erf is correctly observed
that maybe this is a source of that
money but this is a different issue this
issue is should we invest in CFI I think
and CFI is a good investment so so if we
are going to invest in CFI
I would rather have it in hb1 instead of
as hb2
do you have a problem with that
I agree with you okay so so I I I want
to hear you go ahead
sorry to make a comment I I have no
problem what you just said but I would
point out that now you're talking about
basically adjusting rates for one
particular
piece of the whole of the whole budget
and we sort of talked about that's not
really the right way to go about this so
I I get the CFI thing I also like to see
a bad thing I think the program's great
but on the other hand if you can't get
people to do it then it's just money
that sits there and doesn't get put to
use right so I think I think we're all
also aligned on the idea that throwing
money at the same rate we're not going
to probably move the needle much on the
total amount of services and we're going
to end up
isolating the money and turn it into a
lapse I think I think that's generally
all agreed on
to your idea though about targeting
rate hikes this is the project that
representative Stringham has been
working on that I'd like him to brief us
on Tuesday where he's at
and and if Mr White can give us a little
bit better data about you know taking
let's say it's a hundred dollars that we
want to add to this and instead of doing
a hundred dollars thinking we're going
to get a hundred dollars of services it
really needs to be
increase
the rate
by 60 so that we can go spend 40
on on more services you know I there's
there's a formula in there I I think
you're going to come back with a rate
recommendation on this if I if I heard
you right I I can come back with with a
number so if you took the 15 million
dollars that was intended to fund both
existing service levels and additional
projected needs so there would be a
potential reduction in Services what
that would equate to
in a rate increase
okay because this prioritized need was
for both maintenance of services and
projected additional needs and I can try
to cut that a couple of ways so we could
do what's maintenance minus projected
what would the rate increase there be
versus if I took the full 15 million and
applied that to rates what would the
rate increase be there is that
correct
I'll let other comment I I lost you a
little bit I I I have in my head sort of
this graph that it's hard for me to
describe but basically you know if we if
we don't increase the the rates I don't
see how we're going to spend more money
on more services
if we increase the rates a little bit
we're going to hopefully see an increase
in services
if we increase the rates too much
we won't have any money to pay for the
extra services that are now in demand
so so there's sort of a Goldilocks
balance here between money this 15
million going to some rate hike versus
some incremental increase in demand
yeah come on
would you recommend Chris is something
to say and then we'll come to you
I know sorry Chris Antonello associate
commissioner I just wanted to just two
things because we actually are looking
at
um the CFI rates there is um Senate bill
36.
must be something so Senate Bill 36
um and actually Senate Bill 86 which is
looking at rates but one of the things
we actually were talking about today in
Senate Bill 36 is one of the things we
need to do with the choices for
Independence is really look at a true
rate study
um and really understand what is the
cost to provide the services and I think
because in and I think Melissa spoke
about this a little bit
um and Gina Bacchus has also talked is
within the senior services you know we
have different funding streams and they
all have different rates based on the
funding stream but at the end of the day
it's the same Services that's being
provided and so we really want to make
sure we have parity across all of the
different programs serving the same
population and so
what
what so one of the things we've been
looking at is if we look at the three
percent rate increase
um in the governor's budget we also look
at a rate increase in Senate Bill 86 and
at the same time do the rate study so we
can really understand what is the true
cost to provide these services
that's all good that's going to take
time what I'm looking for is is the
short term what can we do to make it
better than it is without you know
breaking something and and if we can
increase the rates a little bit in this
part of Representative stringham's rates
study uh and and then allocate this to
thinking we really will get more
services I that that's that's where I'd
be happy at the end of March everything
you just said can't possibly happen by
the end of March and that's all my focus
is agree I think what I was saying is
just really for the long term
sustainability of the programs and I
think like Nathan said some of these
dollars will go to maintain existing
Services as well
okay
so
um Nathan how much did we lapse in this
area
or how much are we anticipated to lapse
we actually aren't anticipated
um we actually carried four dollars from
last year in to cover services for this
year and then anything that we do not
spend actually gets distributed to
providers so how much did we distribute
we haven't distributed any because we
needed money from last year to cover the
services in this year so at the end of
the biennium we would look to see what
is left and it goes to Providers but I
believe it's projected like under two
million dollars it's not I and and this
is related to account 2152 and the class
note for the 504 where we're supposed to
make that payout and we've been working
with CMS because it technically doesn't
follow standard Medicaid protocol and
we're trying to figure out whether we
can actually do that or not so just
um that's still something that that
we're working through
how
whether or not we're going to be able to
make that payment
I wish I knew it is often difficult
getting a decent and rapid response from
the federal government it took us two
and a half months to get one simple
thing resolved most recently so I'm
hoping soon we'll continue to pressure
them to get an answer
because what would this Pro those
providers will be expecting this at the
end of the biennium
probably planning on it in order to
stay
viable
yeah
so this last part of this conversation
is is a little disturbing to me because
I I think I recall very clearly that we
had this conversation last budget where
this issue of if we can't spend the
money let's give it to the providers and
we had a discussion where I think we all
aligned and agreed that rather than try
to have money at the end that we could
give to Providers we wanted to improve
the rates so that we could provide the
services and the and and the debate at
the time was wouldn't we rather increase
the rates so that we're paying the
providers for additional Services
instead of having them not do the
services and then paying them to do
nothing
and and so I I believe I believe we said
that we should increase rates and not
have money available to just pay them at
the end
am I am I misremembering this Mr Ripple
do you how's your memory
I do remember that but I think there was
a provision added in the Senate that
directed announcement funds to be paid
to the providers at the end of the
biennium similar to what's
similar to what's done with nursing
homes in that same accounting unit
so I'll I'd like to continue to think
that the house position on this is that
we would rather have the money go to
higher rates so that the services are
are provided rather than turn out to be
bonus checks for not providing service
at the end of the biennium
do you is there any argument
on that
well I don't think they're going to be
bonus checks I really don't think
they're going to be bonus checks I think
they're going to be
checks that are going to be really
needed
um for checks for not delivering a
service
but their rates have been way too low
and so in order to keep these agencies
viable and being able to have enough
employees to deliver the services I
think we've either better get the rates
up or you got to give them
what's left over at the end I mean which
doesn't seem like it makes a lot of
sense but we need to get these rates up
I think we're in agreement then it would
be better to get the rates up so that we
can deliver more services than to wait
to the end of the two years to give
checks to just keep the places alive
it sounds like we may I mean it sounds
like we're still waiting to see whether
we can really give those checks or not
okay so what did we decide to do with
we're going to get some more information
from you a recommendation on what we can
get away with in terms of improving
rates here see if it makes sense in the
context of what representative Stringham
is doing so we have like one approach
for our targeted rate increases and then
we'll see what happens to that 15
million meanwhile we still have 18.5 to
look for the county cap
that's my summary
okay
uh 235
section 235 appropriates 20.5 million in
fiscal 23 for maintenance of the mmis
system
foreign
ERS and you gotten aligned or do you
want to wait for him on this I I haven't
spoken with him I can certainly give a
little bit of background I I wasn't here
for it so that I don't know all the
details but during the prior
um budget session we had included the
mmis maintenance costs in in our in our
hb1 agency request during the
legislative process that was pulled out
and put into an hb2 provision there is
an ongoing uh Capital uh appropriation
for the overhaul of the mmis system for
the modularization so to speak of the
mmis system but but the costs here come
primarily directly from our from our
contract with conduit for the ongoing
maintenance of the Medicaid system which
all Medicaid providers in this state are
registered and and through which we
process all those claims so this is a
this is a critical key function and and
the the amounts here as as I am
understand it and I'm waiting for some
additional detail from Dave weeder's are
primarily driven by the specific costs
that we that were contracted for
Okay so
so starting in on this I
I I'm perfectly okay with having the Mis
mmis supported but but I think what we
tried to do last term was to take the
one-time expenses related to the upgrade
of mmis and put it into hb2
and then have the ordinary operations of
the mmis continue to be in hb1
so that we would have like an
operational ongoing year over year over
year over year Baseline of comparison of
what it takes to run the system
but because there was a major upgrade of
20 million dollars or whatever it was
thinking that was a one-time investment
we put it into hb2 as sort of a
standalone that's what I think we tried
to do
so now that I see another 20 million in
hb2
it makes me wonder
what happened to the 20 million that we
put in the hb2 last time
does this make it 40 million dollars to
do upgrades or and and if this is really
meant like I heard you say that this is
meant to be operations leasing of the
system
this should be
in hb1 not hb2 because it's ongoing
operations correct so if you if you turn
to page 924 that's our Medicaid
management information system accounting
unit and that's where historically we
have budgeted
um our our maintenance costs for the
Medicaid management information system
which is uh it's it's it uh this is a
very poor choice of words but it's a
massive complex system and so
historically you'll see like the actual
spend there the thirty five thousand
dollars primarily coming out of the
contract line and then a little ought to
set aside and current expenses
um that is where it is typically paid
from did you mean 35 million
you said thirty five thousand oh I
apologize 35 I'm sorry I've worked until
10 last night it's Friday no no it's all
right it's all right I I just want to
make sure I'm looking at the right
number yes yep it's 35 million dollars
it was actual expense in 22 and so
in the prior um
so it would definitely be my preference
to have this as part of the operating
budget going forward
um and the amounts that we put forward
this year are actually slightly fewer
General funds in 2223 it was 12.4 13.1
million dollars of General funds in 22
and 23 so we're slightly less than that
for this biennium
okay so just to make sure I'm tracking
with what we're agreeing on
you you I think you're agreeing that
this hp2 item 235 this 20.5 million
there's some portion of this that really
is meant to be operations
and that that should be moved out of hb2
and into hb1
is that is that accurate that is
accurate one challenge that I think is
before us is that this appropriation is
made with the state 20 State fiscal year
23 Surplus dollars
so when you said that this 20 million is
the maintenance contract what's the 35
million
so there's the 20 million but there's
also the language to accept and expand
the federal funds associated with that
so
um
it's approximately
it's it's it's it's almost uh it's
almost a 25 general fund a 75 Federal
fund spend that that we're able to get
matching dollars for
okay let me ask my question wrong so I
understand that you're trying to get
surplus funds from this year to use for
next year
if that was not a game that needed to be
played would this just be a 55 million
dollar figure
I mean is that the only reason it's in
hb2 because it's surplus funds
the reason that it's in hp2 is because
it was in hb2 last time and in order to
hit the three percent we were unable to
get incorporated into our operating
budget okay so then last time was it the
same game there was 35 million in hb1
and then 20 million in hp2
I mean roughly I don't need exact
numbers but I'm just trying to
understand the concept that we're
playing here yep so so last time uh in
state fiscal year 22 there was uh 45.5
million dollars in 22.48 million dollars
in 23.
total funds General and federal so is
that yes
yes sort of sorry I'm being verbose yes
correct okay so so would that imply that
it was put into hp2 this time
primarily because to capture the funds
from the Surplus
I I can't speak to that okay
I
so so here here's kind of one of my
dilemmas but I guess the Dilemma is
mitigated by the fact that we're
essentially reserving 23 Surplus to
spend in the next budget
it would it would it would it would help
me to know
if it were true especially
that that Surplus is because we
underspent what we intended to spend in
the one-time implementation of the mmis
upgrade if if we had an mmis upgrade
plan and we had money budgeted against
it and for whatever reason we weren't
able to spend it in a timely basis
having that money roll forward into the
next fiscal year I got no issue with
that makes sense
what I'm trying to track is
he gas this is a lot of money so so how
do we how do I I don't yet feel
comfortable knowing how much money we
spent on upgrades last the current
budget and how much we expect to spend
on upgrades in the next budget and what
the operations
Investments have been over the two
budgets I'm I don't have a clear picture
so I I think this I I could have Dave
Weavers come down on Monday for our
working session maybe we can talk some
of this through because I think we have
to remember we have a large Capital
appropriation over here for the long
term you know kind of the five six year
modularization of the mmis system and
then over here we have the ongoing
maintenance costs so every time we do a
waiver anytime we have a rate adjustment
every time there's eligibility changes
or any federal law regulations change we
have to have our contractor constantly
upgrade those systems right and those
are good hb1 numbers yep yeah and and I
and Investments and upgrades that are
meant to be one time I I can see as an
hb2 item go ahead representative right I
mean I think the distance you're trying
to draw which hopefully David can an
answer is there's the maintenance
contracts on things which have nothing
to do with upgrades and then they also
had the big upgrade thing which is what
he's referring to here but nice to know
what the separation is between those two
in all these numbers both going backward
and going forward of course so so the
dilemma here is that in the ways and
means estimate I think we have like 111
million dollars short of the governor's
budget
um and so
um so when we get around division one
two and three
and people start looking at big numbers
you know if we're going to have the big
number I have to be able to explain it
and right now I I am not able to explain
it it's too big a number for me not to
understand
I'm not opposed to it I just first I
want to understand it and then I want to
have it allocated between HP one and two
and
in a good principled away
all right so if you can help me with
that I'd appreciate it are there
questions comments
okay this do you think representative
Holt's going to have questions on this
is that we should now let's go forward
then
okay so we haven't done anything with
235 except for ask for more details
uh 237.
237 appropriates funds for elevated
enrollment unwinding related to the end
of continuous enrollment
so I have a question about this I
understand what this is but shouldn't
there be a corresponding reduction
accounted for somewhere in other words
we're starting to disenroll people but
we're talking about having more money to
get them disenrolled and I understand
part of that is the fbap is dropping
down and people are appealing and maybe
not necessarily dropping off but some
people should be dropping off
right
sure so
people will be dropping off
um but we're only able to disenroll a
certain percentage of them each month so
we're not able to go ahead and try to
disenroll the hundred thousand or ninety
thousand people you know day one because
we we have to remember that as as those
people re-enroll because some of them
may be eligible we don't want to have an
annual cycle of where 50 000 people you
know I'll I'll go to re-enroll on the
same day every year and so that's that's
part of the process
um but but your your thinking Medicaid
budget big picture
if if if we are seeing these individuals
come off the rolls why aren't we seeing
a larger decrease in spending
um I think Henry lippman when he's been
down here he's pointed out that one of
the biggest areas of um enrollment
growth has been in the expanded medicaid
area and and that's a 90-10 match and
and again you're not you're not
necessarily seeing that in the in the
accounts um within our budget today and
because that's a 90-10 match a smaller
dollar amount is needed for that but but
because it's a 90-10 match 90 being the
federal government 10 being the general
um we're not going to see though those
those kind of expected decreases in
spend but nor do you have the costs
I mean they're picking up 90 90 of it
yes you know basically I think what
you're the six team and it's a pretty
darn precise number here
I'd like to see the equation that I'm
sure you must have been or somebody did
the whole fmap thing over the next nine
months or whatever it is yeah I can
absolutely share that spreadsheet okay
thanks sure
represent an order
um
thank you Mr chair
did weird
the question and 234 and 235 I think we
brought up the issue of whether or not
they should be in house bill one so did
we decide no we weren't doing that or
did we finish that discussion or I I
think I summarized it but just to make
sure I communicated it right Mr White
what do you what do you think we agreed
to on 235
what would I like you to agree to or
what do I think we don't know what we
actually did
I I think we agreed that I needed to
bring Dave down here to give you more
information so that you have the
decision available to you my preference
would be operating budget so we we can
get it back in the operating budget
because we do expect it to continue to
be an ongoing cost into future biennia
and to the extent that there is
legitimate one-time Capital kind of
thing so that's okay to live in hb2
we I just need to know where it's going
to go I I would agree yep but I would
like to clarify one thing I want to make
sure representative norgren's okay
go ahead uh representative Waller
so I'm going back to the unwind of the
Medicaid sure
um that's all in 23 also that's all um
this year's
Surplus so how does that how is that
going to work are you going to
put that in I mean you're going to use
it over the next year right yes yep
that's correct it's coming out of the
state fiscal 23-year Surplus for what we
you know what will be a one-time expense
again the Medicaid unwind and continuous
enrollment is a bit of a historical
anachronism
um so so we would roll that into our
standard Medicaid account and Chip
account and and use it to pay for those
costs there
so I think I'm okay with it here
right you guys have a problem with this
as written and being in hb2
okay
well you'll let us know I'm sure okay so
go ahead Mr Ripple
239 appropriates 838 000 for the purpose
of funding an audit of the integrated
eligibility system
I wondered why it wasn't in hb1
this was originally included as one of
our prioritized needs
capturing fy23 and they're rolling 23
money forward yeah
is it and I think this is the only way
to roll 23 money forward as an hp2 isn't
it this is the only vehicle for that yes
yeah
go ahead can I set a really basic newbie
question so if we're taking 23 funds
from the Surplus to pay for these items
this has nothing to do with
the revenue estimates or the governor's
budgets in terms of cutting however we
could take this Surplus okay the first
part of the statement was true has
nothing with Revenue estimates second
part is it definitely relates to the
governor's budget
because we could have taken These funds
and applied them elsewhere gotcha I
appreciate that clerk still learning
I don't think what I learned what I I
thought I understood from that q a
you know I I
I I think I think when we take fy23
money
and roll it into a need
or something that's going to be in the
current budget
we do it kind of outside the governor's
budget it's it's outside of that budget
it um
and I don't I don't see it affecting the
governor's budget because it's a way to
not do an end run but it's just a way to
have you know a parallel spend that
doesn't show up in the in the governor's
budget it it it it it
um
this is something that Senator Moore
seemed to be really good at right so I
guess if you're we're sort of splitting
hairs at this point you could say it's
not on the budget it's kind of like the
Medicaid expansion thing it's not on the
budget either but okay
you just grab either way you want to but
well I'm just trying to understand it if
I were new to this and I feel like I'm
new every day how I would try to
understand it and I would try to
understand it that that if we did not do
this rollover of 23 money into a future
expense it would instead end up going up
into the rainy day fund and then if we
had a problem
we'd have money up in the rainy day fund
but bringing money out of the rainy day
fund just for operational kinds of
things is more problematic because there
are a lot of rules that we are supposed
to follow when we spend rainy day money
on things well that's true okay but we
could also do it for some we use it for
some other purpose we could play the
same game the governor's playing okay
we're going to kill it here but we're
going to put it somewhere else in still
pull that out of surplus and dump it
into
like the county cap for instance
right so so one way to find the 18 and a
half million is if there's some other
Surplus in FY 23 that we want to pull
forward into helping us with that 18 and
a half million correct but essentially
you're reallocating part of the
don't call the governor's budget but
call the governor's use of the surplus
funds from 2023.
all right I I won't call it that because
it's too many words but uh
one last clarification in my brain so
when we talk about
finding
money to cut to to meet the revenue
estimates is this 2023 money something
if we cut let's say we decide the 20
million for the mmis thing which of
course we're not going to do but if we
decide that 20 million we're going to
cut that and save that off the budget
does that 2023 money count
I think it depends what you do with it
well what you said a few minutes ago is
exactly true if you don't spend it on
anything else it goes into the rainy day
fund and then it's effectively
unavailable to spend in 24 25 unless you
dip into the rainy day fund which is
much harder to do which is one of the
reasons that you see all of the spending
in fiscal 23 is the governor is spending
it down before it goes into the rainy
day fund okay
foreign
I'm just I'm just thinking you know the
two-year 24-25 is the governor's budget
but you're absolutely right your
semantics were perfect and when we
discuss sorry when we discuss a total
the governor presented a budget with
this total it includes all of this in
hb2 and these two oh I got I got a nerve
and the 23
well it does depend on how you define
the budget if you're defining it as
House Bill one then no it doesn't
include the 23 money but if you're
looking at the governor's Surplus
statement or the Surplus statement that
our office will put together for the
legislature then yes it will show that
fiscal 23 spending
okay
if this was easy everyone could do it so
go ahead so I just want to check with
Kevin about something else so people
toss around the number of 131 million
dollars uh revenues are less 131 million
dollars from the governor's budget and
when they say that they're talking about
the governor's budget as being House
Bill one
um his the house Revenue estimates are
131 million below the governor over the
three-year period 23 24 25.
um
so the other thing which I've mentioned
before is yes the revenue estimates are
lower but the governor also had about a
330 million dollar uh cushion if you
will in that he put money into the rainy
day fund at the end of 23 he put money
into the rainy day fund at the end of 25
and he leaves funds in the education
trust fund at the end of 25. so if you
add those three things together the
governor had about 330 million to spare
so the house
You could argue has about 200 million
dollars to spare but again that split
between the education and trust fund and
the general fund and is split over the
three years so how you choose to
allocate That Money Matters
which is why I would be leery of taking
too much out of 23 and putting it into
24 and 25 instead yep
okay so that's a general caution be
careful moving 23 money into the future
okay is there anything specific that
you've seen in hb2 that we should
specifically focus on with the red flag
no I don't think so
um my only thought is if I were looking
to move money between years I would be
trying to find one-time expenditures in
24 25 that you could move into 23 rather
than the other way around
okay
all right
um
so
where are we two thirds did we just do
to 241 yes you're on 241 which
appropriates 533 000 for the purpose of
moving one District office
so is that 23 money
it says it is huh is it
yes it should be a one-time project does
that meet the Ripple criteria
I don't know that I have a specific
criteria
um
my only my only thought is as I said if
you see anything that looks like
one-time spending consider spending it
out of 23.
can I ask him a question go ahead so I
get that that makes perfect sense to me
but how do we get the budget to look
right I mean in the long run because the
problem is doing next time we're on the
budget cycle it's not clear what was
spent
in past budgets and and I do understand
that and if you're comparing House Bill
one from one biennium to the next it
will not show the whole picture and I
completely agree in order to see the
whole picture you would need to go to
the Surplus statement
which is why the the this principle
seems to be important to me is that as
much as possible we should be trying to
make sure that we put operational
ongoing monies into make sure that it
that gets into HP one and then if we
have a real one-time requirement put it
into hb2 we agree yeah but he was sort
of saying for instance a little while
ago I asked him about putting a million
dollars a year from base B2 and HP one
he's kind of saying well we probably
shouldn't do that that's not him and he
wasn't singing directly but you but
that's that's where it goes if you if
you follow his and it's a good point
that you suck it out of 23. because it's
sitting there but the point is I was
just trying to ask how do you balance
that against getting the what you are
just said getting the budgeting stream
yeah
okay any any other go ahead could you
just remind me what district offices is
that we're moving
this is
I'm sorry
I I believe
um commissioner Weaver had reference to
um Claremont is coming to mind that's
been I know that's been a challenging
space okay thank you
just a general comment that seems like a
lot of money to move and that's what
seems to be a small office but
um but I'll I'll I'll leave that
do we want to go on now to 243
section 243 appropriates two hundred
thousand dollars for the replacement of
vehicles and equipment at New Hampshire
hospital
okay all right
next
section 245 appropriates 1.5 million
dollars for the purpose of hiring I.T
Consultants to manage projects and
perform analysis to streamline business
processes
yeah so
so this gives me a rash because it feels
to me like this these this consultancy
money
ought to be associated with one of the
projects like for example the Mi mmis is
being funded
the the project management cost should
be part of those expenses for that
entire effort and and so this seems to
be sort of this free-floating group of
Consultants that aren't attached to a
deliverable
so it may be best
um to wait to have that discussion so I
can have Dave leaders here so he can
explain to you how this would work
um particularly in support of our sales
force enterprise system that we have
okay so if it were tied to a specific
system that would help and then if it
were tied to a specific system that
needed a one-time upgrade then living in
hb2 is kind of compatible with the way I
view this but just having humans
coming in at an hb2 level and attached
to anything just doesn't feel right
sure yeah I'll I'll have Dave come down
I'll see if he's available on Monday and
we can get into specifics okay any
comments on that all right thank you
so section 245 appropriated funds to
manage projects and perform analysis
section 247 appropriates funds to hire
I.T Consultants to develop and Implement
automated solutions to streamline
business processes
so everything I just said I'd say again
249 249 appropriates 125 000 to replace
a legacy database used for pulling
quality samples for food stamp
eligibility reviews
I'm I'm feeling okay with that anyone
dispute it
okay go ahead
section 251 appropriates 410 000 to
replace switches routers routers and
wireless access points at HHS district
offices
okay this is where it gets a little
dicey a lot of that feels like it wants
to be one-time money but but when you
get into something that has such a short
life span like a switcher router
Wireless Technologies it that to me that
feel it feels like that really ought to
be more on an operational side of the
budget
do you have a difference
well yes I mean it's the ones that are
buying at one time and they're not that
short-lived I mean these things will
last three four five years at least you
think the last over three years I have
these things yes
okay no I get that's that's a
depreciation issue right yeah I mean if
it's if it's if it's shorter than three
years this should be operations money
well you believe this is more than that
that
the point is it's sort of one-time money
for from and these things are not very
expensive I mean I get what you're
saying it's not a wrong it's not wrong
but if you can suck it in and use it out
of if they need them they need 400 000
worth go out and buy them
okay any comments other comments
questions
okay
section 253 is the three million dollars
per year and 24 and 25 to ensure that
the TANF maintenance of effort
requirement is met
so we discussed this what what do you
think the takeaway Mr White is for what
we want to do with this line item what
would the division three would like to
do so just to see if you've heard us
sure
um my unders I don't know if I heard a
explicit conclusion but my understanding
was there seemed to be an appetite for
moving this into an hb1 operating budget
Miss Ripple
well so this would be an operating
expense and it would be appropriate I
think to put in house bill one in 2425 I
still would like to get for the
committee that breakout of TANF funds
throughout the budget
um
and and admittedly part of my rationale
for that is
I looked at that breakout from two years
ago and it looked like the maintenance
of effort requirement was met and it
seems to me that most of the funding is
going up so I'm sort of wondering why
the maintenance of effort requirement is
not being met in the operating budget
and it needs to be met here as well so I
think seeing that breakout would
probably be helpful for the committee
okay but Mr White I think had the right
summary Point we'd like to get it out of
hb2 and into hb1 so that our maintenance
of effort is is taken care of okay
all right any representative walner
this is just the a place where I'd like
to ask this question
so we have a TANF Reserve fund is that
correct yes
it's sort of like thinking of a having a
savings account
it's off budget right I wish mine was
that large but sure oh yeah
um how much is in the Tanner freezer
fund at this point as of January 1 I I
haven't checked it recently it was
approximately 67 million dollars
yeah and explain to us how that can be
used
so there are four general purposes that
TANF can be used for I don't know them
off the top of my head Chris I don't
know if you
have a better insight into historically
what types of projects have been used
for that
has the four purposes it's to maintain
I'm gonna I'm really paraphrasing right
but it's like maintain two parent
households to reduce
um po poverty increased self-sufficiency
so really the TANF balance dollars
should really be used for programs in
that area so that could be in some home
visiting programs or child care you know
if we use it
um sometimes to avoid a wait list in
child care we would then pull
um our TANF balance dollars
okay during the last budget
in-house Bill two there was the
provision
that if
Child Care monies for the scholarships
were drawn down
that you could use TANF Reserve funds I
think you had to come to fiscal to do it
but they were some of those some of that
67 million dollars could be used yeah
that there wouldn't be a wait list and
so that kids wouldn't lose child care in
the middle of January or something and
we chose we chose to not put it in the
budget Child Care budget but to have the
language that we can use TANF balance so
it doesn't get tied up except it isn't
here
oh but I don't think we need I think we
just have to go to fiscal to request a
transfer where do you see that
see see which where do you see that if
the child if a child care wait list
develops
that you could use TANF Reserve money by
going to fiscal so we so we would just
go through the standard accept and
expend process to accept those federal
dollars from the TANF Reserve into the
budget to be able to spend those
if we put that provision as it was in
House Bill 2 last time
you wouldn't have any problem with that
because if you can do it anyway and we
specify in House Bill 2 that you can do
it
I think it would make
make it would actually I think make the
Child Care Community feel more
comfortable sure yeah yep yeah it was it
was chapter 91 section 325 and it
requires a quarterly report to fiscals
so it doesn't look like fiscal committee
approval was required yeah yep and so if
we put that in there again
we would not be opposed to that I'll
continue to get the quarterly reports
yep okay and I mean the division has to
decide whether we put it in or not but I
would like to see that provision put in
again if possible I I I I haven't
thought about it I'm open to listening
to you but okay uh maybe we should maybe
we can draft it up and if you see it in
writing then it'll look there the 67
million that's in in the piggy bank I
think you referred to it as uh balance
is that Federal money or state money
it's federal dollars all right so we
can't take the 67 million as a source to
pay for our maintenance of effort
I wasn't sure what kind of money we had
sitting in the in the piggy bank
all right go ahead
but
those funds could be used I mean just
like if we had a wait list for child
care they could be that's because
so if our TANF
roles increased
they could be used to pay for our TANF
rolls
that would be appropriate
yes and we also have used the TANF
balance dollars to help us with some of
our Cliff effect items to help families
get you know
um
mitigate the cliff effect knowing we had
that TANF um balance dollars
sure sure so I'm wrapping up now because
uh the chairman uh needs this room at
five o'clock and we should be clear and
so I'm going to give the chairman back
his room
um uh to do a quick a quick wrap up uh I
you know I we made good progress I I was
thinking we could get through the entire
thing but we didn't so one one do you
think we could start biting at this
again Monday or Tuesday I think Monday
morning you could pick up right where
you left off
okay
um all right uh does anyone of the
division have any final thoughts or
comments that they'd like to make
Mr Ripple you have any
final thoughts Mr White
Chris yeah okay all right so with that I
would say everyone have a great weekend
if you drink don't drive if you drive
don't drink and we're done